hi
um this is on computational harness
needed for Quantum cryptography and this
is Joint work with three cab brokerski
around Connecticut
so let me start by telling you
um about the computational hardness
or classical cryptography and there
there is this very Central notion called
one-way functions which are functions
that are easy to compute but hard to
invert
and on one hand given the existence of
only functions uh already allow you to
do a lot of very non-trivial
computational cryptography this uh
include secretary encryption signatures
their knowledge and so on
and but more importantly on the other
hand
if you take virtually any cryptography
that is information theoretically
impossible so non-trivial encryption
commitment or even more fancy Primitives
like
multi-party computation it turns out
that they would all imply the existence
of only functions so having one-way
functions are necessary for constructing
this kind of uh computational
cryptography
um and at least for the theory of
pornography it is a very important
question to understand what are the
computational hardness needed for
instantiating various cryptography
so after Decades of cryptographic
research now we have a somewhat good
understanding of the landscape of
classical cryptography
and there is this very uh
uh influential uh
terminology
um by impagularzo which is Imperial the
Spy World
in particular there is this world that
is called mini crit where one function
exists but not any other kind of more
fancy cryptography
um and as I already mentioned even
having only functions you can already do
a lot of very meaningful
um
cryptography
but uh
on the one hand this also tells you that
we are not living in the world that
impact level cause algorithmica where P
equals MP
and as we know
um the problem of whether P equals MP is
actually a very long-standing open
question
and therefore there seems to be a
barrier
as a consequence to proving the
existence of following functions or the
existence of all of these wonderful
cryptographic protocols that we would
like to do
on the other hand there is also another
world that impacted will cause
cryptomania where there are more fancier
cryptography that you can do
these include a public key encryption
key exchange multi-party secure
computation and so on
and they are they living in this
separate world because it seems like you
cannot construct these more fancy
cryptography from uh only the existence
of our functions certainly not in a
black box way
and now
uh let's uh consider Quantum
cryptography where Quantum cryptography
simply means that even the honest part
is participating in the protocol will be
able to use quantum mechanics so for
example use quantum computers or even
Quantum communication
and
starting in uh from the work of bb84 we
already know that uh once we you enable
Quantum protocols then you can in fact
do information strategic uh information
theoretically secure key exchange which
is something that uh seems to uh require
very strong uh classical harness to do
since it lies in the world of
cryptomania
and
subsequently there has been a lot of
work uh trying to study this phenomenon
notably ending in two works from last
year by barter SEC at all and gorilla at
all where they showed that you can
actually do
um secure Quantum multi-party secure
computation
uh from only the existence of quantum
secure one-way functions
furthermore
um
after after those two work there are a
few more work
where it has been demonstrated that you
can in fact through Quantum multi-party
computation without even the existence
of alloy functions
and the idea is that there is this
notion of plant and pseudor Randomness
which turns out to be uh sufficient for
constructing a lot of quantum
computational cryptography like NPC or
signature
on the the other hand
these things seems to be strictly weaker
than the existence of one-way function
notably uh in the work by krashner at
all
they subsequently show that there is a
classical Oracle separation of this
object called quantums of this soda
Foundation Randomness from the existence
of one-way functions in particular there
is a concrete way of doing quantity
Randomness without
relying on the security of one function
in fact uh it might be secure even if
only functions do not exist
therefore we can see that uh
once you start considering Quantum
protocols it seems like the landscape of
cryptography seems to change
dramatically since previously we have
all of this crypto Mania
um objects now we can all seem to be
able to do them without even minicrypt
therefore it is a very natural question
to or an actual research direction to
try to understand
uh what is the landscape of the quantum
cryptography
and in this work we are going to focus
on the following concrete question which
is that we uh is there still a minimal
assumption for computational Quantum
cryptography just like how y function is
considered minimal for a lot of
classical computational cryptography
and the object that we are going to
study uh in this work is called EFI pair
but first let me introduce its classical
analog called which we call efid pair
and on a high level the idea of efid
pair is to capture uh non-trivial
computational indistinguishability
so a little bit more formally this is a
classical randomized algorithm that
samples one of two distributions either
distribution zero or distribution one
okay and it is supposed to satisfy the
following criteria which captures the
formal notion of non-trivial
computational indistinguishability
the first notion is that in order for it
to be useful these uh distributions
should be able to generate it
efficiently or sample division
in other words there is a uniform
randomized algorithm G the samples
either from distribution 0 or
distribution one running in polynomial
time
and in the end it outputs some
distribution over this string either
distribution 0 or distribution one
and the second criteria is that it's
supposed to satisfy statical furnace so
distribution zero and distribution one
of the discrete bar so in principle
there is an inefficient way of
distinguishing these two distributions
and finally these two distributions
should be computationally
indistinguishable
so for any efficient
um Quantum algorithm
you will not be able to distinguish
um the distribution Zero from
distribution one except with negligible
advantage
and in fact the classical version of
this has already been studied by gold
rate 30 years ago where he has shown
that the existence of this object is in
fact equivalent to the existence of all
its functions
and in this one we consider the most
natural Quantum analog of this object
which is basically uh the same thing as
efid but now we replace distributions
over B strings with distributions of our
Quantum States or in other words mixed
States so now we have mixed state 0 and
mixed day one that is supposed to
satisfy non-trivial computational
indistinguishability
so uh we have the same three criteria
from before but we suitably changed them
so that they now correspond to a Quantum
State instead of distribution over this
strings so more specifically we consider
efficient Quantum algorithm instead of
randomized algorithm that generates
these mixed States instead of
distributions over this strings
these two mixed States satisfies with
scope furnace where the part the
distance is captured by Trace distance
which is the Quantum State analog for a
total variation distance
and finally they still should satisfy
computational indistinguishability
against Quantum efficient adversaries
the one natural question you might ask
about EFI is that since this is a very a
very very natural generalization of the
classical notion efid show them
everything we know about efid
immediately carry over to EFI by
suitably changing
um all the other technicians and so on
well obviously this was built at a
superficial level because on the one
hand we know that the existence of efid
is in fact equivalent to the existence
of only functions
but on the other hand the existence of
efy pair cannot imply one-way functions
at least in the Black Box way and this
is because the quantum pseudo Randomness
object that we talked about before does
imply EFI
and uh combining this with the Oracle
separation between this and one-way
function we know that EFI you should not
be able to construct when we functions
from EFI
and this uh would prove to be a lot of
trouble because a lot of classical
equivalences between our functions and a
lot of other mini [ __ ] crypto they
crucially go through the existence of
noise functions
and therefore uh you cannot just take
those ideas and put it over to EFI and
it usually wouldn't work
but of course you may say maybe this is
just an artifact of how you define
one-way functions
maybe if you change the one-way function
definition to maybe uh some suitable
notion of quantum awareness then this
issue would go away
unfortunately there is something even
more fundamental than that that will
also would rule out that approach
or at least a thing to show that our
approach wouldn't work and the reason is
that there is a fundamental difference
between how classical algorithms
generate Randomness versus how Quantum
algorithms does it in particular in
order for a classical algorithm to be
randomized it has to take some random
coins as input or random table
on the other hand a Quantum algorithm
can just sample Randomness by itself
as a consequence
um there are a lot of classical proof
technique for approaching randomized
algorithms wouldn't carry over to the
quantum setting
one uh very commonly used technique is
to assume a certain randomized algorithm
is with a lot of generality
deterministic
by convex combination
and another common technique more
relevant to
um
uh the setting of flowing functions is
the uh technique or programming
randomness
which means that you can uh take a
randomized algorithm and then put
arbitrary bit strings on its random tape
and this is something crucially invoked
in the uh very phenomenal work by Hill
where you construct classical study
Randomness follow a function
and therefore in order to deal with or
prove equivalences about EFI will in
fact use quantum techniques
so in this work uh we summarize uh what
we know about EFI in the quantum world
as follows
on the one hand
the existence of EFI in the content
setting does imply a lot of strong
meaningful Quantum cryptography this
includes fiscally secure commitment
schemes oblivious transfer Quantum
multi-party computation
protocols and furthermore we are also
able to show how to prove all of qip or
P space using Quantum computational
neural knowledge proofs
and on the flip side we also show that
if you take all of these uh
cryptographic
uh Primitives and consider a much
weakened version
then they would also imply the existence
of EFI
so the weekend version more formally
means that first of all they does not
need to satisfy any notion of the Cisco
security
and furthermore they only need to be
secure against semi honest adversary for
a Quantum version of the semi-owned
setting
and finally for MPC or two-party
communication uh or on the computation
of their knowledge proof
you only need to construct uh protocols
for non-trivial functionalities or
construct proofs for non-trivial
languages and all of these were loading
facts are immediately imply the
existence of EFI
and therefore to put everything together
there seems to be a very robust
equivalences between
EFI and all of these Quantum
cryptographic objects
okay but oh let me also
um
tell you uh
some other things we note about EF5 here
so in addition to the uh equivalence
that I just talked about
um we argue that EFI pairs serves a
similar role as one way functions in the
quantum cryptography World in particular
like when we functions EFI pairs are
existentially equivalent to various
Quantum cryptography which we just
talked about it is very simple
um
in particular there is this just one
simple notion of EFI there is no various
variance of EFI
it is also very natural uh in fact its
classical analog has already been
studied by gold rate 30 years ago and
there are also related Quantum version
that has been studied for example by
Watchers when he was studying a complete
problem for qsdk
it is also seems pretty minimal because
it is not too hard to see that it is in
fact immediately implied by various
Quantum cryptography like
um on the encryptions and various
consider Randomness Notions like to
random States and super random unitaries
um
finally
um as we show in this this work EFI pair
in fact served as a linchpin for
demonstrating equivalences between
various content uh
okay
so I will not have time to talk about
the the specific constructions of these
equivalences if you are interested you
can take a look at the paper let me
instead conclude with some of my old
favorite Urban questions
um in this direction
foreign
important open question I think is
whether we can construct the contents to
the randomness objects that I've talked
about before from EFI pairs
in other words can we uh have a Quantum
analog or Quantum State analog of the
classical celebrated result of Hil
in particular can we construct through
random States from EFI
another conceptually very important uh
direction to consider is to compare EFI
pairs with unforceable security
or you can call it quantum one way in
this if you want so these kind of
objects includes Quantum signatures
content money and so on where the
security is a search type assumption
finally
um as I mentioned earlier
um because we cannot prove the existence
of Point function unconditionally due to
the barrier of P versus MP
um but for Quantum cryptography or EFI
so far we do not have any evidence of of
having a barrier like what we have for
classical crypto so can we either
unconditionally prove the existence of
EFI appears or are there uh barriers for
proving that they exist
so that's all I wanted to talk about
today thank you very much for attention